all right guys
bang bang i'm here with will we're gonna
break down this
on chain metrics how you doing man i'm
good bob how about yourself
i'm doing all right let's just jump
right into it seems like uh
after two weeks ago when price was going
absolute crazy felt like it was just
dropping
uh and there was no floor now all of a
sudden we get in a situation where
there's a little bit of relief
and bitcoin has come back uh so maybe
just give us a quick overview like what
did you see
in the zon chain metrics uh this week
yeah sure so i guess we can just kind of
roll through you know give kind of a
high level overview of the newsletter we
put out
uh this morning so you know i think it's
some key takeaways from the
you know what we put out this morning
and just kind of the general trends
through the week are you know first of
all
there's you know a clear rotation from
short-term holders to long-term holders
um
which which is interesting um especially
in comparison to
trends in previous uh cycles which we'll
get into
um exchange flows have kind of reversed
uh last week we were talking about how
we had seen a lot of coins moving on to
exchanges before you know wednesday's
dump
um but i think now we're starting to see
you know
nothing crazy but those coins um we're
now seeing
net outflows from exchanges uh which
which is showing we're in somewhat of
accumulation
um and then also we're seeing new
entities coming onto the network
um which we had been trending down and
new entities coming onto the network for
perhaps the last month or so so seeing
that in the last week
last last two weeks is really showing
that
new entities are probably getting
attracted by lower prices
and then the last thing it it miners are
not accumulating as heavy as they had
been
i think for the entire time that we've
been doing this we've we've consistently
been talking about how
minors are accumulating more and more um
but we've actually kind of seen a
plateau in that behavior
um so so so for some like kind of
short-term
uh you know support resistance zones i
think one big one
above us is the 200-day moving average
which is around like 40
000 750 41 000
and then also 50 000 obviously and then
53k
and then obviously 59 to 60k and those
are
i think kind of confluence between
technical sports
and on-chain supports based off of based
off of volume
and then to the downside i think um you
know
30k obviously but then if we lost 30k
i don't see a lot of support between 30k
and 20k
um and so those are the two main zones
and i'm looking to the downside but
we're really just kind of chopping in
this range got it
let's talk a little bit about these
accumulation addresses i think a lot of
people don't actually know what those
are
and then what they've been doing over
the last week or so so maybe just start
with like what is an accumulation
address
yeah so uh accumulation addresses are
addresses that have received at least
two
funds um i mean at least two
transactions inbound
so i i think glasnote does that because
by by using two instead of one inbound
transactions it kind of eliminates like
one one-time use addresses right um
so it's people basically that are buying
bitcoin moving
moving more btc into the address but
aren't moving any out
um and so there's that but then there's
also the balance of those addresses
so um i think you need to look at both
of those things because
you know those accumulation addresses
might be going up but the balance in the
accumulation addresses might be
sideways or it might be down which is
showing it's it's more retail coming on
um versus if you see the the balance in
the wall and the address is really
having a strong leg up in in confluence
with the accumulation addresses going up
then i think that shows that there's
some larger entities
um but you know in the last seven days
we've seen about seven
let's see i have down seven thousand
four hundred thirty uh new addresses in
the last seven days
so it's looking like there's some new um
you know at least in the short to
midterm kind of people that
that are you know scooping up these
coins at these levels
um they aren't necessarily swing trading
but you know they're just
they're just kind of accumulating
perhaps maybe they're they're looking to
you know
capture a bounce up into 50ks but
they're not they're not
selling very short term um and then you
know over time we'll see if some of
these accumulation addresses become
long-term holders
but for now yeah they're not selling um
the accumulation that like the addresses
all together they've added 47 thousand
uh
270 new coins to to their holdings so
um i i think that that that's healthy to
see
like we were just saying the the balance
go up in confluence
um with the addresses got it and so it
feels like in in
some way you've got one these
accumulation addresses lots of those now
being able to be identified on chain and
then most of the coins that are being
sold
are between like one day old and uh
one month old or one week old and so
this seems to be more traders that are
actually anyone who is selling is more
of a trader
yeah um you're seeing a lot of selling
from
you know more than usual from uh coins
under 24 hours
um you know these are coins that are
being moved in and out and
it's you know really just just traders
moving it out of the market
so i think seeing this seeing this spike
in
in
the younger cohort selling i think this
is kind of showing that
traders aren't really um confident at
these price levels in either direction
because we've really just been trading
in this call at you know 32
33k and you know 40k at the top of the
range we've just been trading in that
little channel
um since since the crash so i i think
it's just showing that a lot of these
guys are just kind of swing trading
buying it buying it you know at the
support at the bottom and then trimming
at resistance and
i think you know i've talked to a couple
traders over the last few days i had
this guy
on one of my i do the twitter spaces and
um
his name's crypto cred um but he's
really good with the ta and he was
saying yeah i'm
you know myself and other people that um
i know that are technical traders we're
just waiting for
uh confirmation to the upside we're not
gonna you know try to try to
they're okay with giving up some of the
upside in in return for being confident
in their entry
um so i think right right now people are
kind of hesitant to
to go along um or you know short for
that matter i think
people are just waiting for the market
to kind of make a decision
and then like the futures open interest
is is pretty flat too so i think
that's showing people are kind of
hesitant to jump back into the market
after
you know last week got it and so it does
seem like while the traders don't really
know should it be long or short and
they're kind of doing more of the
the short-term optimization long-term
holders
seem to be drastically still
accumulating right people who don't care
about short-term price movement
seem to be unmoved by any of this price
volatility and they're actually taking
the opportunity to buy more
yeah and and you know that i think it's
really interesting because
at the same time we have we have the
long-term holders that have been adding
to their you know holdings over the last
seven days
and then when you look you know it's
almost like inversely correlated the
the short-term holders um have been
trending down
so you get this and you know i don't
know if this is a really good thing
because
obviously you want to continually you
know have coins move to people who
aren't going to sell
but i think it would be nice to see some
some new market participants come in and
stay i don't think i don't think that's
a
that's a great thing um obviously in
in terms of you know building up that
that
base of of coins um in terms of price
but just in terms of adoption
i think it would be better to see new
you know new entities come on
um but i mean that's not that's not the
end of the world but i think what's
interesting is
you know when when we get to the
previous like at the top of cycles
um you start to see you know retail
really overtake
um a lot of the movement um in in you
know
in and out of exchanges and volume and
things like that
um and and they start to uh
take up a larger portion of supply and
at the same time you see
the longer term holders sell off and
then in the bear market you see the
opposite all the short-term speculators
move out because bitcoin went down 80
and you know when we get to the bottom
um of the bear that's
that's peak when when long-term holders
are accumulating because they've been
through multiple
um cycles so i think it's interesting
right now that you're seeing
and and this is one thing that if i had
to look at something that was
that looked like a top it would be this
because
um you're starting to see the long-term
holders um take up a larger portion of
supply again
while short-term holders are are
trending down meaning you know they're
selling
where you know in in previous cycles it
it's almost like these lines had had
crossed where
where you know short-term holders really
ramp up their holdings
and long-term holders begin to kind of
sell into the strength you know mid to
into the later phases of the bull market
so that's something i'm keeping my eye
on because that's not something that's
happened in previous cycles where midway
through the cycle
um you've seen the short-term
speculators step out while the long-term
holders are
you know uh coming in and scooping up
those coins but for you know
this prolonged period of time i just
think that's interesting
what do you think the ramifications of
that would be does that signal maybe
potentially a bigger
bull market a longer bull market maybe
not a crash
uh you know at some point in the future
or we don't know yet
yeah um i i think it it's showing that
we're
we're building this this stronger base
up um obviously you know
it's not great for the adoption like i
said but i in terms of the coins
you know uh being locked up and and
building up this floor i think
that this is good um in in that sense so
yeah i think
if if this you know if this continues
and and
coins continually are moving to um
these these long-term holders um perhaps
we're in this you know strong
accumulation zone
um but it's just a question of can well
you know
if if if that were the case um how you
know how long are they able to kind of
hold the floor
while while new sellers are are moving
out um
and you know what's the offset between
those two forces but
um i think it's i think it's kind of
neutral um i just
i think if you if you see um continued
accumulation by um long-term holders and
this trend continues now where i'm
seeing
this this reversal where the short-term
holders are are selling off and
long-term holders are continuing to add
um i think perhaps the the structure of
the like the underlying forces behind
the cycle are
perhaps different than previous ones
what's up guys before we continue with
this interview
i want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses
so whether you're an og or this is your
first trade
kraken has all of the tools that you
need to achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin ethereum
and many many more kraken also provides
in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today
again that's kraken.com bang bang all
right let's get back into this interview
i hope you're enjoying it
and so what else are you seeing on the
on chain metrics there's some stuff
around like entity growth that you wrote
about
yeah so um the glass notice this metric
called net entities growth and you can
basically just think of it as like
net user growth on the network um so
glass node kind of you know forensically
uh clusters different addresses into
what they believe
looks like a certain entity so an entity
can be a person a corporate treasury an
investment fund
what just looks like one um one one
group
or one you know and i don't know another
synonym for entity but i think that's
pretty straightforward honestly
but they they subtract um
the new the new entities coming on the
network from
entities that have no balance and and
they
they look dormant so there's no action
coming from them for a prolonged period
of time
um and then also they have no no btc um
so
they subtract that difference and then
you get net entities growth
um we that had actually been trending
down over the past
month or so but but now
over the last week and a half two weeks
you've seen a new leg up in that so
um it's overall it still looks like it's
in a downtrend but we have seen like
this really sharp
almost v-shaped recovery in in the new
entities coming on the network
um so perhaps this is retail because
retail retail uh the the smaller
entities call it like point zero zero
one to
one btc those are trending up um
in terms of how much supply they're
holding and then also the number of
whales is trending down
so to to say that that the new entities
are you know you're seeing this leg up
in new entities while there's
a move down in the number of new whales
coming onto network
to me that shows that it's it's it's you
know uh
retail or um holders with this with
smaller amounts
got it and then talk a little bit in
terms of the um
idea of selling at a loss on aggregate
versus actually coming back to
break even as uh people offload some of
these uh bitcoin
yeah so this is a metric called soper
it's something that we've we've touched
on in in previous pods um it's basically
the
the aggregate uh profit loss of of the
market on any given day
um when when you see the market at a
loss on on aggregate it
it's something that's not not so common
in a bull market because
people aren't going to be willing to to
sell at a loss when you know when
bitcoin is going parabolic but when it
whenever we do see these dips into
you know where the market selling at a
loss it usually doesn't stay down there
for a long period of time
um and we're actually seeing a pretty
sharp recovery in that where the
market's now
back in in net profit no longer in net
loss
um so i think that that's kind of
showing this this rebound in
whoever was going to kind of capitulate
because you know what we had
last wednesday was really a capitulation
and then um
liquidation um so
i i think whoever is going to capitulate
it it appears that they've already done
so got it and then what about
uh kind of miners what were they doing
this week
yeah so you know for a while we had been
talking about how the miners were
stacking really hard and they just kept
adding to their positions over the last
you know month and a half
um but what what i've seen on chain in
the last um
call it you know 10 days or so is is
you know this this plateau in in miners
accumulating so glass node looks at you
know all the the minor balances they
have a metric called minor unspent
supply
and so you know right around may 10th
um it kind of topped out and since then
we've just kind of been going sideways
which is i guess i guess market neutral
because
um you know they're not they're not
accumulating as heavily as they have
been but they're not
dumping necessarily either but you know
i have seen a lot of selling coming from
chinese miners which is interesting
because um
i heard some talks about you know the
ccp
uh cracking down on on different uh
mining pools
um and then also something about the the
wet season and then they have to move
their um
you know their their machines to you
know a different location
um um i might be misquoted on that but
um it it definitely is is showing a lot
of sailing coming from these chinese
miners particularly one
is uh poulin which i looked up was the
the second largest
um chinese pool um for miners so
i i think that's interesting it i
definitely um
contributed a little bit to some of the
selling last wednesday there's a big
spike in
coins moved uh two exchanges from poland
um but
yeah i'm seeing this this trend in um
selling from from chinese miners over
the last week
got it and then what about uh the actual
bitcoin on the exchanges it seems like
that was a little bearish last week
but uh may have uh have flipped this
week
yeah um you know i think for the entire
cycle
there had been this this narrative kind
of driving uh
you know at least from the data side
that you know the coins are being moved
off the exchanges
and then they're moving into deep cold
storage never to resurface again
um but it you know over the last month
or so we've
really started to see these coins come
back on exchanges in a big way
and especially leading up to last
wednesday we saw a lot of coins moving
on to exchanges
which was kind of this early sign that
perhaps we were getting ready for this
dump especially in the hours leading up
to
you know call it tuesday wednesday um
but you know after when after wednesday
we're starting to see that kind of
reverse
so um i think
we kind of touched this at the beginning
but you know they're not necessarily
super bullish
like we're not seeing these massive
amounts of coins coming off exchanges
but they're no longer um net inflows to
exchanges
so it is showing that people are are
taking coins off at a
bigger rate than than the people are
moving coins onto exchanges
so i think you know that's just showing
some accumulation but
it doesn't look like there's any um
crazy capitulation
coming um you know in the short term
just based off of that because it seems
like people are now accumulating again
slowly
got it and so would it be fair to say
that kind of in summary
uh you know two weeks ago things were
a little bit more uncertain than they
are now definitely there was a lot more
selling some capitulation
this week it seems like while we're not
completely out of the woods
uh things are more positive looking like
there's been some relief for recovery
um and ultimately uh the bull market is
still intact and it's got a lot more
room to run
yeah i think um we're in this
interesting zone here where
you know it it the short term price
action is is definitely
could go either way um but it yeah i
think it's starting to show
some some promising signs um especially
after wednesday
we're we're definitely seeing at least
this kind of relief bounce here
um but i still remain bullish for the
longer term cycle i think
um you know this is just kind of
this big consolidation um and this this
big shake out that
i still see us going higher based off of
kind of the the broader metrics
but uh yeah i think you know
i in the short term i remain kind of uh
optimistic but skeptical i guess you
could say
where um it's starting to look like
things are turning around but
um you know it's not screaming like this
thing is about to
you know explode so um i
i think in in the short term it's just
kind of a market where you just kind of
sit back and
watch and let the market tell you more
absolutely
and then uh before i let you go tell us
a little bit about how the email is
going you
you recently launched and it seems like
it's growing pretty quickly um
but uh just remind everyone about that
uh that email that you send out a couple
times a week
yeah man so um you know every friday i
send out the newsletter on pomp sub
stack but then on monday and then
sometimes on wednesdays
um if needed i send out a newsletter on
my sub stack which is a
btc by wc3.substack.com
i think we're now up to almost 16 000
subscribers
which has been super awesome you guys
have been you know super supportive i
appreciate it
but if anybody's not subbed to the
newsletter go ahead and do that i really
appreciate it
awesome well listen i'm enjoying this
i'm learning a ton uh i think a lot of
people are really enjoying uh these
videos
uh so thank you so much for doing this
and just keep us updated on what's going
on
on chain and we'll do it again next
saturday
thanks a lot bob take it easy man